the telescope was really the machine
that changed the world the most and
what's so cool about it it it acted like
a lever that moved the Earth from being
the center of the universe back in
Galileo's time what year did they invent
it the telescope was invented around the
early 1600s and there's a popular
misconception that Galileo invented it
but he he didn't he actually perfected
it so he took it from like you know zero
to one this is the best Christmas gift
you could possibly get a kid because
with it you can see the same craters on
the moon that Galileo saw light
pollution does not obscure the you know
the planets light pollution does not
make impossible I'm not advocating for
light pollution but I'm just saying
right here in the middle of Austin or in
the middle of San Diego I can see the
exact same things that caused Galileo to
realize that the sun is the center of
the solar system using scientific
reasoning and evidence based on
observation he realized he discovered
another solar system a system in which
there was a massive gravitating object
Jupiter and around it were orbiting
satellites we orbiting moons around it
today they're called The gilean
Satellites he actually named them after
his benefactor those patrons the medich
who were the richest you know people in
in that part of Northern Italy so he
named he was clever right he was trying
to Curry favor made this it would be
like if we named the uh the you know
whatever the higs B on WE name that
after you know the European uh you know
T equivalent of the IRS right he was
kind of a kissing a kiss up you know
it's sick of f but it had to save his
life and he needed money and so but when
he drew that he realized the wait a
second the Bible and all teaching here
to for said there is only one Center to
the solar system and and and it's the
Earth not the sun this is called
geocentrism everybody believed that
Aristotle uh Plato everybody had
believed that for a long time because it
said it was natural that heavy things
should fall towards a center and the
center that everything seemed to fall
towards was the center of the Earth or
the Earth itself therefore the Earth
must be the center of the universe
remember the solar system was the
universe for a long time then for an
equally long time almost the Galaxy was
the whole universe and now there's the
universe and maybe the Multiverse that
we'll talk about so this was just
incredible realization to him imagine
like you come upon this thing and you
realize you're the first person in human
history ever to feel that is there any
uh documentation of his struggle with
trying to convey these ideas to people
that had very strong religious beliefs
yeah because obviously it it turned out
to be a catastrophe for him that's right
but what did he did he convey in his
writing the frustration that he had he
was he's such a fascinating person I
always make a provocative statement that
like we don't need English departments
we should just teach like physics and
astronomy because some of the great
scientist of History men and women were
tremendous orators they were tremendous
writers and they could convey things
through the written word that was pure
Artistry and Mastery and Galileo would
say things like I do not believe that
the same God who has given us senses to
understand the world would require that
we not use that and I'm butchering the
quote not use them in order to better
understand it he would write things that
he had discovered things um you know
only as a way to open a portal into the
universe such that mine's more astute
than mine may be able to walk through
this portal and he was being a little
falsely um humble but uh Newton was the
same way Newton would write as a great
or so you can learn a lot from
scientific writing so therefore if you
only had to choose one thing I would
take the books of Galileo and this
geocentric version of the universe that
they've how how is it written in the
Bible like how do they describe it's
actually you know the atheist so I I I I
call myself a practicing agnostic which
I can Define later if you like but you
had on my friend Stephen C Meyer which
is you know partially the reason that
I'm here I think um but uh but to have
the discussion about you know the
influence of religion on science and he
made the claim that without religion we
wouldn't have science on the show a
couple weeks ago in other words we
wouldn't have the the tradition that we
can that the world is intelligible it's
not the capricious will of gods you know
uh playing with human beings as Greeks
and and others had had identified um so
the uh the notion of you know how
religious science could be or how
religion impacted him was very clear he
would say he was a very religious person
in fact two of his daughters were nuns
and and because of his um you know I
always say like imagine we're living in
a time where someone like Anthony fouchy
or you know Francis Collins or somebody
that they had they were not only the
scientists the expert scientists say but
they also controlled the government in
other words the most powerful force on
Earth at that time at least where
Galileo was was the Vatican he never
left Italy he never left Italy didn't
exist back then by the way they were
only city states right Tuscany and V
Venice and and Rome and so forth but the
the notion it was a Catholic you know
band of jurisdiction and Catholic church
had sway over that part of Italy and
Tuscany where he was he was very
religious um but he he thought that he
could say things like if he proved that
something scientifically was true he
didn't understand why that couldn't be
part of the religious Cannon so he was
surprised in other words he he felt that
this signature of God is truth so if he
discovered truth it wouldn't be a
problem for the it would be threatening
but I argue back then it was kind of
threatening like if you started having a
bunch of people say oh the Bible's wrong
we've been misled and they're the
government not just scientific Authority
they're the government um it could lead
I'm not saying it's good but it could
lead them to want to suppress that right
because it could lead to insurrections
it could lead to whatever um and and
rebellions and that could be perceived
as very threatening to the
state